So my God, I
always get the most terrible beating with black. Let's see if
I can fight white wars or
not
lose with black. First of all, there is no
opponent
Alka from
Israel
2295 knight C6, which is of course
unusual, well E5 would like to prevent it better,
yes well rale can first of all  It can't be wrong,
so the question now is whether you
play C4 here or whether it
has any meaning here, well I'll say C4,
it can't be that wrong here,
so let's think about it now the
question is directly Queen A4 with the idea of
Knight E5  I could have bishop E4 Zen
but I have knight
C3, well let's try to get the thing
back. Covering is going
badly, an idea that might
be sensible, knight D7
might have been there, so
knight E5 somehow makes sense here, well at
least at least it destroys the
pawn position so structurally  Now it looks
very pleasant,
but Black
typically always gets a bit of
play Rook
B4
h that's a bit unpleasant D4 is a bit
weak I'm so well
developed I could of course take C6
if he moves Rook B4 Yes I'll try
a bit not exactly ideal but I
want to  catch up on a bit of development
so tur B4 dam C6
UPS rook B4 so that
C6 rook D4 bishop E3 ​​actually looks
like a good development yes of
course D6 is like a sausage
well4 so now he still has the
two weak pawns there
A7 C7 and pretty much  absurd rook on D6
that will get a few more kicks
yes that looks like a
comfortable
position
so now you could of course
access A7 D A7 D7 bishop A7 rook D2
but he has h I don't really
like bishop C5 is an
option  would have to move D7 ah yes I
have a settlement that is at least
very pleasant
and now bishop E7 queen rook
rook E7 and queen
A3 that is very pleasant so that B2 covers
economically
and now we can initiate further
exchanges
in the end there are still the
two of them  Pawns behind there weak
check well that's not the end of
the world for black
but certainly more pleasant for white so
I would like to swap the queen too
yes where does he want to go after D4
maybe could
move E3
yes yes swapping the dam would be
nice
maybe
queen
B4 could be his intention here,
it would relieve him a bit,
definitely good, how about e.g. B3 B3 Queen
B4 takes takes knight B5 hangs C7 well
he has bishop A2 but or bishop
B1 A2 is something stupid hm so B3 looks looks
stupid
I'm going to make another
move
there for good reason,
hm yeah, it's really great, isn't it,
you don't have to
fool yourself, so
good, I was hoping that
somehow it would still
be something, so I wanted to try knight to B7 now,
of course he can do bishop
E4  take bishop E4 I could even
take bishop B1 I play A4 war
at least a passed pawn
aha
time
warning knight
B7 so now he wants to go there okay so to
C6 if I now play bishop G2
t looks like C5 is gone now
or just bishop  C6 I have the wah
knight C5 or bishop E4 bishop E4
bishop E4 knight C5 I then have the
pawn
more yes
come on let's have a look here King
D6 h is somewhat
active
well yes anything but easy although F5
is of course helpful that he is  puts it on
white
Check yes I have to I only have
8 seconds of help so okay now but really
quickly
Check Check Check
Game
dra yes there wasn't much missing
but of course I was clearly too
slow so before that there was
a lot of strange game
somehow good  Okay, of course that's good,
maybe this process was
bad, the king is already
here very quickly,
or maybe I have to play E4 E4 E5 E4
E5,
well maybe knight schl C5 is
better here knight schl C5 knight C5
bishop A6 bishop C6 knight D3 I thought
then somehow unpleasant B3 knight
C1 I'll probably have to do it anyway,
okay